[Música]
em geral quando a gente pensa na palavra
metamorfose a gente identifica
metamorfose como uma transformação da
forma como por exemplo quando a gente
pensa numa borboleta que nasce de um
estado inicial de lá para se transformar
num lindo ser vereador a gente aplica
essa palavra também a outros animais
mas se a gente pensar profundamente a
gente vai ver que a gente pode aplicar
aplicar essa palavra nós mesmos nós
também sofremos metamorfose no nosso
início a gente é um embrião a moto ea
gente vai se transformando gradualmente
momento o momento até se transformar
nessa forma que nós temos hoje ou mesmo
na forma de quando a gente era um bebê
mas essa transformação da forma que a
gente tem feito vida pós vida não tem
feito de nós pessoas melhores
nós continuamos sofrendo e continuamos a
fazer os outros sofrerem é botar nos
ensina uma transformação mais radical
ele nos ensina uma transformação de um
ser comum para um ser iluminado um ser
iluminado nunca sofre nunca faz ninguém
sofrer pelo contrário a função de um ser
iluminado e beneficie a cada um todos os
dias todo o tempo
essa é uma transformação significativa a
gente pode imaginar a nós mesmos por
exemplo como um ser iluminado imagine
você como ser iluminado
imagine você podendo beneficiar todos os
seres todo o tempo
dissipando a dor de quem tem dor
aquecendo quem tem frio refrescando quem
tem calor sendo um refúgio para os
outros
imagine você sendo assim hoje a gente
entende que a gente não consegue fazer
isso nem com os nossos entes queridos
nós não conseguimos ajudar as pessoas
que nós mais amamos porque a gente não
consegue porque a gente é um ser comum
ea gente precisa se transformar num ser
iluminado mas muda nos diz que todos nós
temos essa o tência lidade dentro de nós
nós podemos ser um ser iluminado nós
podemos nos transformar e como que a
gente tem que fazer isso
modificando os nossos estados mentais
negativos na positivas e por que a gente
não fez isso até agora porque a gente
está valorizando muito mais o nosso
exterior do que o nosso interior
a gente valoriza a forma e não aquilo
que dá forma forma o que dá forma forma
muda nos ensina que o que dá forma à
forma é a mente de onde vêm de onde vem
a nossa vida
de onde vêm todas as pessoas todos os
insetos as montanhas do planeta todo o
universo de onde vêm todas essas coisas
muda nos diz
não há outro criador que não aumente
se a gente entender isso nós vamos
entender que transformando a nossa mente
nós podemos transformar aquilo que dá
forma à forma
isso sim é uma transformação
significativa profundamente
significativa eu especificamente eu tive
a imensa boa fortuna de conhecer a
doutrina de buda há 12 anos atrás eu
vivia tentando transformar as formas que
me apareciam atentava todo tempo
transformar minha vida para que ela se
adaptasse aquilo que eu desejava que ela
fosse eu tentava transformar as pessoas
e as coisas
isso me dava uma profunda insatisfação e
sofrimento porque eu nunca tinha sucesso
um dia passando numa rua e eu vi um
banner com a foto de hoje quem é o meu
guia espiritual e venerável deste que é
o sangue atsu em cima dessa foto tinha
uma frase que dizia assim mude sua mente
mude seu mundo
eu estava cansada de tentar mudar o
mundo de tentar fazer o mundo ficar
formatado pra mim e aquilo me impactou
profundamente eu então imediatamente
peguei o telefone liguei e a pessoa do
outro lado me disse eu perguntei
olha como eu faço para saber mais a
respeito dessa frase aí a pessoa do
outro lado me disse olha vem aqui amanhã
tem uma aula às 20 horas
o resto da história não vou contar já
está contada né
ou seja tão vendo e aí talvez vocês
possam pensar mas eu não quero virar um
nojo e eu não quero virar um monge mas
não é esse o caminho a gente não precisa
nem mesmo cortar o cabelo que a gente
precisa transformar nossa mente
transformar as nossas intenções mentais
esse é o processo de transformação
furar a monja foi uma opção minha foi
algo muito particular da minha vida
mas então vocês não precisam transformar
o seu externou a sua forma
o que a gente precisa tomar nossa mente
e aí a gente pode se perguntar algo
importante
eu disse que eu sofria porque eu queria
mudar as coisas que apareciam pra mim
como uma maioria de nós quer a gente
vive tentando mudar os outros mas porque
que a gente quer fazer isso porque o
tempo inteiro a gente quer mudar as
situações que aparecem para nós porque a
gente tem um equívoco de percepção
a gente acredita que as coisas que nos
aparecem são causa de felicidade
sofrimento
nós colocamos essa qualidade nas coisas
mais felicidade sofrimento são estados
mentais são sensações
não é possível que algo fora
mude algo dentro nós temos que mudar
nossa mente a experiência a felicidade
se a gente deseja
o que a mente
aí talvez seja uma outra pergunta porque
mente pra nós
muitos de nós identificámos em mente
como sendo algo do corpo
a gente pensa em mente a gente
imediatamente põe a mão na cabeça gente
pensa em cérebro
só que cérebro é uma parte do corpo o
cérebro pode ser visto pode ser pesado
pode ser medido a mente não alguém
consegue enxergar a mente de alguém
a mente é um contínuo vazio e sem forma
sem cores sem cheiro a mente não surge
da forma no cérebro que faz a mente
nascer
isso é um equívoco por isso não há outro
cria mente porque apesar de ela ser
completamente vazia de forma de cor
cheiro é repleta de poder e esse poder é
o que dá forma às formas
se a gente entender isso a gente vai
querer a tensão no nosso interior e
começar a identificar quais são os
nossos estados mentais negativos e quais
são os nossos estados mentais positivos
os nossos estados mentais negativos nós
podemos eliminar porque eles são hábitos
mentais
simples assim são maus hábitos mentais
nós podemos eliminá-los nossas mentes
negativas os nossos hábitos mentais
negativos e aprender a cultivar os
nossos hábitos ou fazer disso não é
cultivar as nossas mentes positivas
isso é uma grande transformação
e isso sim dá um imenso significado
nossa
existência transformar nossa mente é na
dependência desses estados mentais que a
gente o tempo inteiro segura que a gente
responde a vida quando as coisas
acontecem para nós
se nós estamos sustentando um estado
mental negativo a gente responde com um
estado mental negativo
se a gente está sustentando um estado
mental positiva a gente responde
positivamente é na dependência desse
estado mental que a nossa vida feliz ou
triste não na dependência das coisas que
aparecem para nós mas a gente pensa
muitas vezes que estados mentais são
características nossa são partes da
nossa personalidade a gente fala isso a
gente fala só assim eu sou assim porque
eu sou de câncer
eu sou assim porque eu sou de escorpião
por que plutão tem no seu que retrógrada
do com saturno ea gente fica tentando
justificar mas qual é o signo qual é a
pessoa de um determinado signo que não
sente raiva que não sente orgulho que
não sente inveja que não sente ciúme
todos nós sustentamos mendes negativas
não importa qual o signo
essas coisas não são parte da nossa
personalidade de novo são hábitos
mentais e por serem hábitos mentais elas
podem ser eliminadas completamente
completamente quando a gente pensa nisso
a gente vai ver que a gente pode usar
esta vida para mudar os nossos hábitos
mentais
isso é fazer da nossa vida uma vida
plenamente significativa mudar a mim
mesmo para mudar meu mundo porque a
gente tem essa familiaridade com essas
mentes negativas o que sustenta essa
familiaridade
o que a gente tem familiaridade é só
perguntar quantas vezes a gente sente
raiva por dia muitas
então o que está essa familiaridade no
budismo a gente chama é somente de alto
apreço é a mente que só pensa em nós
mesmos ea mente que diz o meu desejo
importa
ele precisa ser satisfeito a minha
felicidade importa e ela precisa ser
satisfeita e o meu sofrimento é maior do
que qualquer um e eu preciso eliminar o
meu sofrimento agora pensando assim e
retendo esse pensamento ou negligência
todos os demais entre a minha felicidade
dos outros
a minha que importa entre o meu
sofrimento dos outros
o meu é maior enquanto gente
negligenciar os outros
trocando eles por nós mesmos
nós vamos continuar a sofrer tem um
grande mestre indiano que diz toda a
felicidade do mundo vem do desejo de que
os outros sejam felizes e todo o
sofrimento do mundo vem do desejo de que
o mesmo seja feliz
nós temos uma leitura equivocada da vida
a gente acha que a nossa vida a gente
está vivendo ela simplesmente para nos
mimai nos encher de prazer custe o que
custar
não é essa a finalidade da vida
essa finalidade não vai trazer muita
mudança pra nós
a gente precisa aprender a mudar o nosso
interior
e mudando o nosso interior mudar o nosso
exterior
eu gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
algumas palavras do meu guia espiritual
do que este que o sangue a tsu é de um
livro dele que se chama como transformar
a sua vida ele disse até agora temos
apreciado a nós mesmos acima de todos os
outros
enquanto continuarmos a fazer isso nosso
sofrimento nunca terá fim
todos os seres iluminados descobriram
que abandonando alto apreço e apreciando
somente os outros viriam a experienciar
verdadeira paz e felicidade
se praticarmos os métodos que eles
ensinaram não haverá razão de não sermos
capazes de fazer o mesmo para fazer isso
não precisamos mudar nosso estilo de
vida
o que precisamos mudar são as nossas
idéias e intenções
nossa visão comum é que somos o centro
do universo e que as outras pessoas e
coisas têm sua importância à medida
principalmente pelo modo como elas nos
afetam essa visão auto-centrada do mundo
está fundamentado em ignorância e não
corresponde à realidade
em resumo precisamos dos outros para o
nosso bem estar físico emocional e
espiritual sem os outros não somos nada
nossa impressão de que somos uma ilha um
indivíduo autossuficiente independente
não possui relação alguma com a
realidade é mais próximo da verdade nos
imaginarmos como uma célula no vasco
corpo da vida distintos porém
intimamente ligados a todos os seres
vivos não podemos existir sem os outros
e eles por sua vez são afetados por tudo
que fazemos a ideia de que é possível
garantir nosso próprio bem estar
enquanto negligenciamos o bem estar dos
outros ou até mesmo
custa deles é completamente realista
no começo da minha falha disse que muda
nos propõe uma metamorfose profunda pode
ter uma metamorfose uma transformação
maior que as transformar nossa mente
para transformar o mundo
então agora pra finalizar eu gostaria de
propor uma minúscula meditação na
verdade uma imaginação peço que por
favor você se coloquem na cadeira eu vou
ler algo imaginem isto
imagine imaginem o mundo que todos
queremos um mundo onde todos se
consideram se respeitam
armas sem guerra sem disputa sem fome
sem doenças sem dor sem sofrimento
um mundo de paz sem paz interior é
impossível amásio exterior por ar por
alguns instantes e esse mundo venceu e
agora pensa em tudo o que eu preciso
fazer para construir esse mundo é
compreender que todos e cada um dos
seres vivos é importante e todos devem
ser objeto de meu apreço muito obrigada
[Aplausos]